[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
berry a friend
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
when we all fall asleep or do we go
from the coalition
please welcome studio head Rod Fergusson
[Music]
[Applause]
thanks everyone we're excited to
announce that gears 5 is releasing on
September 10th and if you want to play
four days early you can with our
ultimate edition or membership in the
newly announced xbox game pass ultimate
with Gears of War 4 we wanted to earn
your trust
but with Gears 5 we want to push the
envelope by doing new things never seen
in the Gears game before and will tell
you all about it this summer in July
join us for our vs. multiplayer tech
test well you'll be one of the first to
play our all new competitive game type
arcade in August at Gamescom go hands-on
with the all-new horde mode and see how
character abilities can turn the tide on
the battlefield in September we return
to the biggest Gears campaign ever where
we will explore more of Kate's harrowing
journey and celebrate our launch on
September 10th but what are we talking
about today
today it's a brand new way to fight the
swarm an escape you play as one of three
hive busters you and your squad
infiltrate the hive plant the bomb and
escape with your life because we all
know the best defense is a good offense
it's everything you love about Gears
turned up to 11
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
they attacked and we lost everything
everything except the need for revenge
this might look like a surrender but
it's not it's an impatient
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
I hope you enjoyed your taste of escape
an aggressive three player co-op
experience perfect for your living room
couch but it's not just about busting
hives you can build them too and
challenge your friends with the
experiences you create and tonight
join me on mixer as we challenge these
three WWE superstars
Xavier woods AJ Styles and Tyler breeze
to survive a gameplay deep dive from
right here in the hive for these are at
home for the next two days you and your
friends can play and select microsoft
stores so good luck outrunning the swarm
and we'll see you on the leaderboards oh
and for anyone who pre-orders or plays
within the first week we've got
something special just for you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]